Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. now how would you like to try a free case of fabulous portuguese wine of course you would wouldn't they tom and you are in luck because this episode of the restoo e Historia, is kindly sponsored by Wine 52.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目，并加入我们广受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想获取加更节目、抢先听、无广告音频以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您正在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，只需轻点几下即可在应用内订阅。那么，您想不想免费试喝一箱美妙的葡萄牙葡萄酒呢？当然想啦，汤姆，他们说是吧？你可真走运，因为本期的《历史的余烬》得到了 Wine 52 的慷慨赞助。
And Dominic, their Wine Odyssey this month takes us to the stunning north of Portugal, which of course has very ancient links with us here in England, doesn't it? If an area was a friend of the rest is history, the north of Portugal would be a friend of the rest is history, Tom. For reasons that we will shortly be explaining, because today's podcast is sponsored by Wine52, and because they are promoting Portuguese wine, we thought that we would focus our episode today and the succeeding episodes on the history of Portugal.
多米尼克，他们本月的“葡萄酒奥德赛”之旅把我们带到了风景迷人的葡萄牙北部，这里当然与我们英格兰有着非常古老的渊源，对吧？如果说哪个地区是《历史的余烬》的朋友，那葡萄牙北部绝对是《历史的余烬》的朋友，汤姆。原因我们稍后就会解释，因为今天的播客由 Wine52 赞助，而且他们在推广葡萄牙葡萄酒，所以我们决定将今天的节目以及接下来的节目聚焦于葡萄牙的历史。
Yeah, and Wine52 are offering listeners to the rest of the history three portuguese wines for free unbelievably so all you need to do is to go to www.wine52.com slash history you'll need to cover the postage costs of £8.95 but you will get three free bottles delivered to you and this is very much the kind of thing that wine 52 do they showcase the best wine that comes from a different region each and every month. And you have the choice of mixed, red only, white only case. And also you get a magazine brilliantly called Glug. And you get two tasty snacks as well. I love a tasty snack. I know you do.
是的，Wine52 正在向《历史的余烬》的听众免费提供三瓶葡萄牙葡萄酒，这简直难以置信。你只需要支付 8.95 英镑的邮费就行了，就会有三瓶免费的葡萄酒送到你手上。这非常符合 Wine52 的风格，他们每个月都会展示来自不同地区的顶级葡萄酒。你可以选择混装、纯红葡萄酒或纯白葡萄酒。此外，你还会得到一本名字叫得很妙的杂志——《咕咚》（Glug），以及两份美味的小吃。我喜欢美味的小吃。我知道你喜欢。
Now, after your first case, you will join the monthly wine club. But there is no minimum commitment at all. So if it's not for you, you can pause or cancel at any time. Now remember, it is www.wine52.com slash history. That is, of course, the word wine, then the numbers five and two dot com slash history. And you can claim your case today. So on with the show. Bom dia. The fardo is on. The wine is cracked open. And Dominic, you are full of excitement, are you not? Because today's episode is the first of an epic sweep through the history of Portugal. And you are a huge, is it lucitana file? Would that be the word? I think a lucifile, a lucile hola everybody bienvindo hola tom
第一箱之后，你将自动加入每月的葡萄酒俱乐部。但没有任何最低消费的强制要求。所以，如果它不适合你，你可以随时暂停或取消。再次提醒，网址是 www.wine52.com/history。也就是说，先是单词 wine，然后是数字五和二，点 com 斜杠 history。你今天就可以领取你的那一箱。那么，节目开始。蓬蒂亚（Bom dia）。法多（fardo）音乐响起来了。葡萄酒已经开启，多米尼克，你现在一定满心期待，对吧？因为今天的节目是一场对葡萄牙历史的史诗级全景回顾。而你是一个超级……是叫卢西塔尼亚迷（lucitana file）吗？这是这个词吗？我想应该叫“卢西迷”（lucifile），露西，你好，大家好（lucile hola everybody bienvindo hola tom）。
and uh that is lindo fado lovely fado music that you're playing in the background there very much the atmosphere of a restaurant on the algarve circa 1975 it's amalia rodriguez she's yeah incredibly famous top fado performer i'm gonna fade her down um but, so Dominic, this is a subject that you're very, very keen on. I'm going to put my hands up and say that I am less familiar with Portugal than I should be. When I say should be, every patriotic Englishman should go to Portugal because Portugal is, of course, our oldest ally. And that will be a theme running throughout this history, won't it? It will indeed, because the history of Portugal is entangled with that of England and later Britain. I think it's the oldest surviving alliance anywhere in the world, Tom.
呃，那是很好听的法多（lindo fado）音乐，你在背景里放的那段，非常有大约 1975 年阿尔加维（Algarve）餐厅的氛围。是阿玛利亚·罗德里格斯（Amalia Rodriguez），她是个……是的，超级著名的顶级法多歌手。我要把声音调小一点。不过，多米尼克，这是一个你非常非常感兴趣的主题。我得举手承认，我对葡萄牙的熟悉程度确实不够。我说“应该”，是因为每个爱国的英国人都应该去一趟葡萄牙，因为葡萄牙当然是我们最古老的盟友。这将是贯穿这段历史的主题，对吧？确实如此，因为葡萄牙的历史与英格兰、后来的英国交织在一起。我认为这是世界上现存最古老的同盟关系，汤姆。
In some ways, as we'll go on to discuss, although it's enshrined in the Treaty of Windsor, its origins go back even further. So you could argue this year is the 650th anniversary of the first alliance between England and Portugal. So it seems appropriate that we're talking about Portugal. But also, Tom, Portugal is one of those countries that can genuinely claim to have changed the world, as we will discuss. We have to say for bad as well as good. Yes, for bad as well as good. Darkness as well as light in the story. There is a lot of bloodshed, but it's also the country that in some ways you could argue inaugurated the age, the modern age of globalization, as we'll go on to discuss. And actually, it's a sort of parallel narrative to the narrative that we often tell about the
在某些方面，正如我们接下来要讨论的那样，尽管它被写入了《温莎条约》，但它的渊源甚至可以追溯到更早的时候。所以你可以认为今年是英格兰与葡萄牙首次结盟 650 周年。因此，我们来谈论葡萄牙似乎非常合时宜。而且，汤姆，葡萄牙也是那些真正有资格宣称改变了世界的国家之一，正如我们将要讨论的那样。我们必须指出，既有不好的一面，也有好的一面。是的，既有不好的一面，也有好的一面。这个故事里既有黑暗，也有光明。这里有许多流血事件，但它也是一个在某种程度上可以说是开创了全球化现代纪元的国家，我们接下来会讨论这一点。实际上，这与我们经常讲述的那种……
sort of early modern period, because we're all familiar with Columbus and Cortes and Pizarro and the Spanish Armada and Philip II. But this is a much less well-known, but just as colourful and just as kind of lurid a story. In a way, as significant. Yes, absolutely as significant. Absolutely. But we will come to all that, won't we? Because everything must have a beginning.
关于早期现代时期的叙事形成了一种平行叙事，因为我们都很熟悉哥伦布、科尔特斯、皮萨罗、西班牙无敌舰队和腓力二世。但这是一个鲜为人知，却同样丰富多彩、甚至同样耸人听闻的故事。在某种程度上，它同样意义重大。是的，绝对同样意义重大。绝对是的。但我们都会讲到这些，对吧？因为万物皆有始。
And I thought it would be nice to begin this story, not actually in Portugal, but on Capri, which was the subject of our recent episode on Roman holidays with Tiberius, who people who listened to that episode may remember that Tiberius retired there. And there were lurid stories told about his activities. But there was also an alternative narrative in which Tiberius pondered the mysteries of this and other worlds. And one of the reports that was brought to him, and we get this from a friend of the show, Pliny the Elder, and it says an embassy from Olisipo, which was the Roman name for Lisbon, sent for the purpose, reported to the Emperor Tiberius that a triton had been seen and heard playing on a shell in a certain cave. So a triton is a kind of merman. Great wonder.
我想，以这个故事作为开端或许不错——其实不是从葡萄牙开始，而是从卡普里岛（Capri）开始。这也是我们最近那期关于提比略的罗马假期的节目的主题。听过那期节目的听众可能还记得，提比略退隐到了那里，并且流传着许多关于他荒淫行为的耸人听闻的故事。但也有另一种叙事，说提比略曾在岛上沉思这个世界和其他世界的奥秘。其中一份呈报给他的报告——这个信息来自我们节目的老朋友老普林尼（Pliny the Elder）——记载道：“来自奥利西波（Olisipo，里斯本的罗马名称）的使团奉命向提比略皇帝报告说，有人在一个特定的山洞里看到并听到一个特里同（triton）在吹响海螺。”所以，特里同是一种人鱼。真是奇观。
And I think that the reason I thought this would be a fun way to start it is that it kind of focuses on a key theme in Portuguese history. And that is, firstly, that waves of invaders tend to come from the Mediterranean. So before the Romans conquered Portugal, you have the Carthaginians. And subsequently, you'll have the Moors, all coming from the south. But there is a sense that because Portugal is facing out to the Atlantic, seen from the perspective of the Mediterranean, it's absolutely on the fringes of the world. For the Romans, it's fronting what they call the ocean, this great, vast, enclosing wave of salt sea um and and that really sums up the kind of the the the paradoxical quality of portugal that it's simultaneously a mediterranean and uh and above all an atlantic state yeah um i think that's very very convincing tom because if you go to portugal and you you sort of stand on the coast the atlantic coast you look out to see it's a bit like you know it's a bit like when
我想，我之所以觉得这是一个有趣的切入点，是因为它某种程度上聚焦了葡萄牙历史上的一个核心主题。那就是，首先，一波又一波的侵略者往往来自地中海。所以在罗马人征服葡萄牙之前，有迦太基人；随后，还会有摩尔人，他们都来自南方。但有一种感觉是，因为葡萄牙面朝大西洋，从地中海的角度来看，它绝对处在世界的边缘。对罗马人来说，它正对着他们所称的“大洋”——这片巨大、浩瀚、将陆地包围的咸水巨浪。而这……这确实概括了葡萄牙那种矛盾的特质：它既是一个地中海国家，同时……最重要的是，它是一个大西洋国家。是的……我认为这非常有说服力，汤姆，因为如果你去葡萄牙，站在海岸边——大西洋海岸，放眼望去，这有点像……
you go to sort of the beaches of of um the far bit of cornwall and you kind of look out and there's just the sort of the gray seas huge waves the wind the nothingness the tritons yeah the this sort of sense of standing on the edge of almost an abyss yeah um yeah and that sense that portugal is both part of the mediterranean world as across spain is or or Italy or France, but it's also on the periphery and it's kind of on the edge, I guess, that life on the sort of maritime edge. It's really important to Portugal's identity. people originally from Lebanon who found the great city of Carthage in what's now Tunisia, and they conquer southern Spain. And it's from that base that Hannibal launches his famous invasion of Italy going over the Alps with his elephants. And when Carthage is defeated, Rome annexes those Carthaginian holdings, very, very important because full of mines. And that's really what the Romans are after, specie,
这就有点像当你去到康沃尔郡偏远地区的那些海滩，放眼望去，只有灰色的海水、巨浪、大风、虚无，还有特里同。是的，那种仿佛站在深渊边缘的感觉。是的……而且这种感觉——即葡萄牙既是地中海世界的一部分，就像西班牙、意大利或法国一样，但它同时也处于边缘，处在某种边陲。我想，这种海上边缘的生活对葡萄牙的身份认同至关重要。……最初来自黎巴嫩，他们建立了伟大的迦太基城（今突尼斯境内），并征服了西班牙南部。汉尼拔就是以这个基地为跳板，带着他的大象翻越阿尔卑斯山，对意大利发起了著名的入侵。当迦太基被击败后，罗马吞并了迦太基人在当地的资产。这非常非常重要，因为那里到处都是矿藏。这正是罗马人真正想要的东西，金银财宝等等。这也是一个将贯穿整个历史的主题——当葡萄牙自己成为殖民者时也是如此。但实际上，葡萄牙的历史与西班牙的历史是捆绑在一起的。整个伊比利亚半岛……
gold and silver and so on, which again is a theme that will run throughout this history when Portugal itself becomes the colonizer. But really, the history of Portugal is bundled in with the history of Spain. It's the whole iberian peninsula um and it takes the romans a very long time to conquer the whole of the iberian peninsula and northern portugal is is a part of what it takes them a long time to conquer um so uh all kinds of famous names are involved in campaigns against people who are called the lusitanians. So Portugal comes to be known as Lusitania by the Romans. So Marius, great military innovator, Julius Caesar, and then in due course, Augustus, who is the person who completes the conquest. But this idea that northern Portugal is somehow distinct from the south, I think is important to understanding the kind of the geopolitics of the region. And you have, it's a very, very bloody history. It's marked by all kinds of
罗马人花了很长时间才征服整个伊比利亚半岛，而葡萄牙北部正是他们花了很长时间才征服的地区之一。因此，各种各样的历史名人都曾参与针对被称作“卢西塔尼亚人”（Lusitanians）的当地人的军事行动。于是，葡萄牙被罗马人称为“卢西塔尼亚”（Lusitania）。马略（Marius）这位伟大的军事改革家、尤利乌斯·恺世，以及后来的奥古斯都——完成最终征服的人——都曾涉足于此。但这种“葡萄牙北部在某种程度上不同于南部”的观点，我认为对于理解该地区的某种地缘政治至关重要。而且，这是一段非常非常血腥的历史。它充斥着各种背叛、各种大屠杀。皇帝加尔巴（Galba）的祖先在这段历史中就是一个特别血腥、背信弃义的人物。正如英国有波迪卡（Boudicca）或法国有韦尔金托里克斯（Vercingetorix）一样，今天的葡萄牙将维里亚图斯（Viriathus）这位英雄般的本土人物铭记于心，他曾试图抵抗罗马人，尽管最终徒劳无功。但你在法国和英国也能感受到这种态度，即对罗马人抱有一种略带矛盾的情感——你一方面对他们有很强的认同感，但与此同时，你又歌颂那位领导了一场注定失败的抵抗运动的崇高领袖。罗马平定了葡萄牙，并引入了其独特的文明烙印，其中道路当然是至关重要的。因为葡萄牙并不是一个易于出行的国家，对吧？我想你比我更清楚这一点。
treachery, by all kinds of massacres. The ancestor of the Emperor Galba is a particularly blood stained and treacherous figure in this history. And as with Britain and Boudicca or France and Vercingetorix, Portugal today remembers this figure Viriathus as a heroic native who tries to hold off the Romans in vain. But you get that sense that you have in France and Britain as well, that slightly ambivalent attitude towards the Romans, that you identify very strongly with them. But at the same time, you fate the noble leader who leads a doomed attempt to hold them off. Rome pacifies Portugal and introduces its distinctive brand of civilization, of which, of course, roads a fundamental because portugal is not a country that is easy to travel around is it i gather you'd know better than me well i mean that you were
嗯，我是说，你刚才谈到了它的地理状况。所以，我想你可以用一种非常简化的方式说，这里大致有三个区域。北部非常青翠，山谷众多——我的意思是，很多葡萄酒都产自这里。比如从波尔图延伸出去的杜罗河谷（Valley of the Douro）。所以它其实相当郁郁葱葱，而且雨水可能比较多。然后是中部，有阿伦特茹（Alentejo）以及那里的软木林。那里夏天酷热难耐。如果你夏天去的话，绝对是烈日炎炎。
saying about the the geography of it so i suppose you could say in a very sort of simplistic way there are three sort of zones there is the north which is very green and the valleys that you i mean that's where a lot of the wine comes from. So the Valley of the Douro going from Porto. So it's actually quite sort of verdant and it can be quite wet. And then you've got the center and you've got this sort of the Alentejo with these cork forests. And that is really baking in summer. If you ever go in summer, it's absolutely scorching.
而南部则是阿尔加维（Algarve）。是的。阿尔加维，多米尼克，我在那儿烤焦了我的屁股。哦，那可真是一幅美妙的画面。汤姆，那是怎么发生的？我……我躺在海滩上，结果……没有把游泳裤往下拉好，所以到了傍晚……傍晚结束的时候，我的裤子都在滴血，因为晒伤得太严重了。这是怎样一幅离奇的画面啊。好吧，老实说……这就是为什么我再也没有去过葡萄牙。
And in the south you have the Algarve. Yeah. And the Algarve, Dominic algarve dominic is where i fried my buttocks oh that's a lovely image that is how did that happen tom um i i kind of lay on a beach and uh failed to um adequately pull down my swimming trunks so by the end of the end of the end of the day they were dripping blood they had burned so badly what what an extraordinary image that is well i'm going to be i'm going to be honest that's why i never i never went back to portugal
哇，所以你去了阿尔加维——我从来没去过阿尔加维，但在我的想象中，它就是一个巨大的高尔夫球场。这……这算公正的评价吗？我相信是的。我只是从西班牙顺便过去了一下，去了海滩，然后就出丑了。出丑了，没错。不过提到阿尔加维，让我们想起了另一波征服者。罗马帝国崩溃了，西罗马帝国崩溃了，被西哥特人（Visigoths）取而代之。西哥特人是非常非常笃信基督教的，他们确实帮助基督教在葡萄牙扎下了根。但随后，就像迦太基人和罗马人所做的那样，新一波侵略者从南方卷土重来。当然，那就是穆斯林、阿拉伯人、摩尔人、毛里塔尼亚人……
wow so you went to the algarve which i've never been to the algarve but in my mind it's an enormous golf course is that um is that fair i'm sure it is i just went i just nipped over from spain and went to the beach and went to the beach and yeahaced yourself. And disgraced myself, exactly. But the mention of Algarve reminds us of further waves of conquerors. So Rome collapses, Roman Empire collapses in the West, gets taken over by the Visigoths, who were very, very militantly Christian. And they really helped Christianity to bed down in Portugal. But then the next wave of invaders, as the Carthaginians had done as the romans had done come from the south and that of course is the the muslims the arabs the moors mauritanians
随便你想怎么称呼他们。所以是伍麦叶人（Emayads），伍麦叶王朝，对吗，汤姆？是这样吗？嗯，最初不是，后来伍麦叶人来了。我们将在接下来的节目中讨论这一点。不过，我之所以提到阿尔加维（Algarve），是因为“阿尔加维”这个词最初在阿拉伯语中就是“阿尔-加尔布”（Al-Gharb）——也就是西部，安达卢斯（Al-Andalus）的西部地区，大西洋的领地。而摩尔人，就像当年的迦太基人一样，未能征服北部。因此，北部在基督教国王的统治下坚守了下来，这和同时期西班牙发生的情况完全一样。但在此时，你知道，葡萄牙和西班牙……
whatever you want to call them so it's the emayads the emayad dynasty isn't it tom is that right well not initially and then the emayads come and we're going to be talking about this in a subsequent episode but um the the reason that i mentioned al-garb is that al-garb is al-garb originally in arabic so it's the west the western portion portion of Al-Andalus, the Atlantic realm. And the Moors, as the Carthaginians had done, are unable to conquer the North. So the North holds out under Christian kings, which is exactly the same thing, of course, that's happening in Spain at the same time. But at this point, you know, you're portugal and spain um it's really important i i think to say isn't it that um there's no sense of there being two countries called portugal and spain they're just a series of former provinces
我认为非常重要的一点是要说明，当时根本没有“葡萄牙”和“西班牙”这两个国家的概念，它们只是一系列罗马帝国的旧省份。这些省份最终落入了西哥特人之手，后来又大体上落入了摩尔人之手。我的意思是，摩尔人——即使他们没有占领整个半岛——也是半岛上远为最强大的力量，对吧？是的。这就是当时的格局：主要是南部的摩尔人穆斯林势力占据了所有富饶的土地，而基督徒则被逼退到了北部的山区。但这使得他们能够维持某种摇摇欲坠的独立。在穆斯林的庇护下，里斯本成了一座伟大的城市。所以，我们有一位名叫伊德里西（Idrisi）的地理学家，他在11世纪称赞这里的浴室。当时，拉丁基督教世界正在各个前线高歌猛进。那是十字军东征的时代，是西班牙的“收复失地运动”（Reconquista）真正开始全面展开的时代。
of the roman empire that would they were ended up under the visigoths and then by and large end up under the moors i mean the moors are even if they don't take over the whole peninsula by far the biggest power in the peninsula, aren't they? Yeah. So that's the division. It's between the predominant Moorish Muslim powers in the South that have all the kind of the rich lands, and the Christians have been confined to the mountainous reaches of the North. But that enables them to kind of preserve a kind of shaky independence. And Lisbon becomes a great city under Muslim patronage. So we have a geographer called Idrisi who praises it for its baths the 11th century which is a period when um latin christendom is on the move on almost every front so it's the age of the crusades it's the age where
同样的进程也发生在日后将成为葡萄牙的土地上。事实上，正是这个进程赋予了葡萄牙名字。因为当时有一位来自勃艮第（Burgundy）的贵族名叫亨利（Henri，即阿方索一世之父）。他在杜罗河（River Douro）畔、北部大港波尔图周围建立了一种类似于公爵领、伯爵领的政权。这片土地后来被称为“波尔图之地”（Land of the Port），也就是葡萄牙（Portugal）。因为它的名字源于“波图斯·卡莱”（Portus Cale），对吧？汤姆，如果我没记错的话，当时的葡萄牙……
the reconquista is starting to really get going in uh in spain and the same process happens in what will become portugal and in fact it it's this process that gives Portugal its name. Because you have a nobleman from Burgundy who's called Henri, Henry. And he has kind of established a kind of duchy, a county on the Douro, the River Douro, around Porto, the kind of great harbor in the north. And this land becomes known as the land of the port, Portugal. Because it's Portus Calais, isn't it? That's the original. And at that point, Tom, I think I'm right in saying
是莱昂王国（Kingdom of Leon）的附庸。我们可以把莱昂王国视为某种“西班牙性”的发源地之一。所以，在那个时候，“葡萄牙性”和“西班牙性”的概念根本毫无意义。伊比利亚半岛上存在着一种由中世纪王国组成的拼图般的格局，彼此之间的同盟关系无休止地变化着。实际上，你知道人们对……
it's a vassal of the Kingdom of Leon, which we would think of as one of the cradles of kind of Spanishness. So at this point, the idea of there being Portuguese-ness and Spanishness makes no sense at all. There's a sort of patchwork, isn't there, in the Iberian Peninsula of medieval kingdoms, sort of endlessly shifting alliances. And actually, you know the image that people have
“收复失地运动”的印象——那种英勇的西班牙骑士把摩尔人赶出去的画面——其实要更复杂一些，对吧？因为他们总是内讧。是的，他们也在互相打仗。完全是这样。而且他们还会借助摩尔人来对抗彼此，摩尔人也同样在利用他们互相制衡，情况要复杂得多。好吧，摩尔人自己也分裂成了各个王国。所以这一切都相当……
of the Reconquista, which is sort of heroic Spanish knights driving back the Moors. It's actually a bit more complicated, isn't it? Because they're always sort of falling out with each other. Yeah, they're all fighting each other as well. Exactly, and sort of playing off the Moors, it's actually a bit more complicated, isn't it? Because they're always sort of falling out with each other. Yeah, they're all fighting each other as well. Exactly. And sort of playing off the Moors against one another, and the Moors are playing them off against each other, and it's much more complicated. Yeah. Well, so the Moors have fragmented into kingdoms as well. So it's all a bit
相当复杂。基督教贵族如果得到机会，显然很想做的一件事就是去争夺王冠。所以，是的。亨利，有点像——我想——当时的征服者威廉。我的意思是，他是一个到海外寻找晋升机会的法国贵族。他的儿子阿方索·恩里克斯（Alfonso Henriques）也是这么做的。他宣布自己是国王。而这实际上将葡萄牙从一个伯爵领提升为了一个王国。因此，他被许多葡萄牙人视为葡萄牙历史上最伟大的人物之一。我们大概会在以后再回到这个话题，特别是当我们谈到20世纪的时候。
quite complicated. And one of the things that Christian noblemen are obviously keen to do, if they get the chance, chances to claim a crown. So, yes. So, Henri, a bit like, I suppose, William the Conqueror at the same time. I mean, he's a French nobleman who has traveled abroad looking for promotion. And his son, Alfonso Henriques, he does that. he announces that he's a king um and effectively this is what makes promotes portugal from an earldom to a kingdom yeah so he's regarded by lots of portuguese as one of the absolute greatest um people in portuguese history so we'll probably come back to this later on particularly when we get to the 20th century
还记得那个名为《伟大的不列颠人》（Great Britons）的电视节目吗，汤姆？是的，丘吉尔赢了，在决赛中击败了伊萨巴姆·金德姆·布鲁内尔（Isambard Kingdom Brunel），成千上万的人投票。嗯，许多人效仿了这个做法，葡萄牙人也有了自己的版本，而阿方索一世就是其中最热门的候选人之一。我想——我们稍后会谈到那个击败他的人。他出生于12世纪初左右，打过三场战役。其中一场他还打败了自己的母亲，这非常符合中世纪的行为方式。这真的是非常非常中世纪的行为方式。
remember there was that tv series great britain's tom yes which churchill won beating his zimbabwe kingdom brunel in the final and princess hundreds of thousands of people voted well lots of people copied this and the portuguese had one and alfonso the first was one of the top contenders i think i mean we'll come later to the person who who beat him but he's born in about the beginning of the 12th century and he fights three battles. So he beats his own mother in one of them, very medieval behavior. That is very, very medieval behavior.
那是1128年的圣马梅德战役（Battle of Sao Mamede），然后是1139年的奥里克战役（Battle of Ourique）。据说圣詹姆斯（St. James）在那场战役中帮助了他。是的，圣詹姆斯总是会出现，所以那就是圣地亚哥（Santiago）。是的，就像伟大的朝圣一样。没错。
So that's the Battle of Sao Mehmed in 1128, and then there's the Battle of Ulrich in 1139, and St. James helps him in that battle, apparently. Yeah, well, St. James is always turning up, so that's Santiago. Yeah. As in the Great James is always turning up. So that's Santiago. Yeah. As in the Great Pilgrimage. Right.
所以我们认为他是一个加利西亚的、西班牙北部的圣人。但这大概让你体会到，地理上的边界远比现在要模糊得多。最后一场战役是1147年攻占里斯本。所以他当时已经自称为国王了，对吧？是的，他确实自称国王了。
So we think of him as a kind of Galician, northern Spanish saint. But that, I suppose, gives you a sense of how the sort of boundaries in the geography are much more ambiguous than they are now. And then the final one is taking Lisbon in 1147. So he's called himself a king already, hasn't he? He has, yes.
但他基本上还需要一场胜利来让教皇给予认可盖章，并说：“是的，你是一个国王。”所以到了1147年，里斯本围城战爆发了，英国人在这里首次登场。这真是一段精彩的葡萄牙故事。这是一个极其精彩的时刻。
But he basically needs one more victory to get the papacy to sort of give him the stamp of approval and say, yes, you are a king. And so 1147, the siege of Lisbon, this is where the English make their first appearance. Splendid. Portuguese story. So it's a splendid moment.
这也是第二次十字军东征的一部分。所以第二次十字军东征总体来说是一场灾难。几乎没有什么事情是顺利的——这与所有其他的十字军东征不同。好吧，第一次十字军东征——如果你是个十字军战士，那进展简直好得不得了。他们占领了耶路撒冷并建立了王国。但从十字军的角度来看，第二次十字军东征并不成功。不过，里斯本围城战却取得了巨大的成功。参战人员包括大量来自北部基督教王国的人，其中绝大多数是英国人，但也有德国人。还有来自弗兰德斯（Flanders）等地的人。他们从达特茅斯（Dartmouth）起航，在葡萄牙登陆。
And this is part of the Second Crusade. So the Second Crusade generally is a bit of a disaster. Nothing really goes right. So unlike all the other Crusades. Well, First Crusade, I mean, if you're a Crusader, it goes tremendously well. They capture Jerusalem and establish their kingdom. But the Second Crusade, from the point of view of Crusades, is not a success. However, the Siege of Lisbon is a great success. And it consists of a large number of people from the northern Christian kingdoms, of whom the majority are English, but there are Germans as well. There are people from Flanders and so on. And they sail from Dartmouth and they land in Portugal.
然后，没错，你们航行到那里。阿方索说：“你们为什么不帮我攻下里斯本呢？”他们觉得这是个绝妙的主意。于是他们包围了里斯本，最终里斯本投降了。汤姆，你注意到他们的一些名字了吗？他们的领袖叫赫维·德·格兰维尔（Hervey de Glanville）。所以他基本上就叫哈维（Harvey）。
And yeah, so you're sailing. And Alfonso says, why don't you help me take Lisbon? And they think this is a great idea. And they lay siege to Lisbon and Lisbon ends up surrendering. Tom, did you notice some of their names? So their leader is called Hervey de Glanville. So he's called Harvey, basically. Yeah.
还有多佛的西蒙（Simon of Dover）、伦敦的安德鲁（Andrew of London）、班伯里的基斯（Keith of Banbury），以及黑斯廷斯的吉尔伯特（Gilbert of Hastings）。其中有些名字是我现编的。但他们是一群很奇怪的人选。而且我们对他们一无所知，对吧？不，我们其实知道。我们知道他们的表现非常好，不过我得遗憾地指出，跟德国人和弗拉芒人相比的话。德国人！噢，这简直是未来在阿尔加维海滩上行径的预告片啊，汤姆。不仅如此，弗拉芒人也是。所以基本上，比利时人当时的行为也很糟糕。摩尔人同意投降里斯本，双方达成了停战条款。但弗拉芒人和德国人却置之不理。他们开始大肆掠夺。然而，英国人——他们的信仰对他们而言至关重要。
And Simon of Dover, Andrew of London, Keith of Banbury. And Gilbert of Hastings. Some of those I've made up. But they're a sort of strange selection of people. And we know nothing about them at all, do we? Well, we do. We know that they behave very, very well in comparison, I'm afraid to say, to the Germans and the Flemish. The Germans! Oh, this is a preview of behaviour on Algarve beaches, Tom. Well, but the Flemish as well. So basically, the Belgians are misbehaving too. So the Muslims agree to surrender Lisbon and terms are agreed. And the Flemish and the Germans ignore them. They go on the rampage. However, the English, their faith was of the utmost importance to them.
他们考虑到这种行为可能会带来的后果，于是安分守己地留在指定的岗位上，选择不去大肆劫掠，也不愿违背对上帝的义务。我认为这是值得称赞的。这为我们树立了非常好的形象。而且你知道同一个人——同一个编年史家是怎么评价德国人的吗？他们到处乱窜。他们大肆掠夺。他们砸毁房门。
And contemplating where such behavior might lead, they remained quietly in their assigned position, preferring not to go on the rampage and wishing not to violate the obligations to God. And I think that that is commendable. That reflects very well on us. And you know what the same guy says, the same chronicler says of the Germans? They ran hither and yon. They plundered. They broke down doors.
他们搜查每一所房子的内部。他们毁坏衣物和器皿。他们无耻地凌辱贞女。他们的行事作风仿佛黑白不分、是非颠倒。他们比所有人提前半小时把毛巾占在沙滩上……所以这是令人发指的行为。正因如此，由于对英国人虔诚且圣洁的行为印象深刻（这是可以理解的），里斯本的第一任主教便是黑斯廷斯的吉尔伯特。他是小圣埃德蒙兹（Bury St Edmunds）管家的幼子。这太棒了，对小圣埃德蒙兹来说是个好消息。
They rummaged through the inside of every house. They destroyed clothes and utensils. They treated virgins shamefully. They acted as if right and wrong were the same. They put their towels down half an hour before everyone else yeah so shocking behavior and because of this uh understandably impressed by the the godly and saintly behavior of the english the first bishop of lisbon is gilbert of hastings um and he's the younger son of the steward of uh berry st edmunds which is brilliant so that's good news for barry st edmunds yeah
绝对是的。所以，这些全都是非常棒的素材。而且，这也是若泽·萨拉马戈（Jose Saramago）的一部小说的核心主题。你读过那本《里斯本围城史》（The History of the Siege of Lisbon）吗？没有。这本书非常棒。它完全取决于……所以这是一部典型、微妙、聪明的多层含义小说。它是一部运用了多重叙事层面的、典型而巧妙的小说。故事讲的是一个校对员，他被派去审阅一本关于里斯本围城战的书。为了好玩，他在文本中插入了一个“不”字，从而决定篡改一句关键句子的含义。这样一来，这本书现在宣称：十字军并没有协助葡萄牙国王从摩尔人手中夺取里斯本。于是，一切都被颠覆了。你知道吗？葡萄牙人自己流传的关于里斯本围城战的故事，与这种历史叙事完全相矛盾。所以，他们的一位伟大英雄名叫马丁·莫尼斯（Martim Moniz）。据说在围攻城堡时，
absolutely so so that's all great stuff um and it's um it's the theme of um a novel by uh jose sarumago have you read that the uh the history of the siege of lisbon no it's very good and it all depends on um so it's a you know typical subtle clever novel working on multiple levels and it's a typical, subtle, clever novel working on multiple levels. And it's about an editor who is assigned a book on the siege of Lisbon. And he decides just for fun to alter the meaning of a crucial sentence by inserting the word not in the text. So that the book now claims that the Crusaders did not come to the aid of the Portuguese king in taking Lisbon from the Moors. And so everything gets upended. Well, do you know what? The Portuguese themselves tell a story about the siege of Lisbon that completely contradicts the sort of historical narrative. So one of their great heroes is a man called Martim Moniz. And he's supposed to have, in the siege of the castle,
摩尔人正试图关上一扇门。他基本上把自己的身体塞进门缝里，以此来阻挡大门，好让他的战友们能踩着他的尸体冲进去，而当时摩尔人正在疯狂砍杀他。他牺牲了自己。但实际上，摩尔人几乎是在与基督徒达成协议后就主动投降了。所以这几乎是绝对没有发生过的事情。然而，当地有一个地铁站是以他的名字命名的。所以，究竟谁笑到了最后呢？好吧，确实如此。
the Moors were trying to shut a door. And he basically stuck his body in the doorway so that they were to block the doorway so that his comrades could get in past his body while the Moors were hacking at him. And he sacrificed himself. But unfortunately, the Moors actually surrendered the castle deal with the Christians. So this almost certainly didn't happen. But he's got a metro station named after him. So who's laughing last? Well, yeah, it's true.
我的意思是，《历史的余烬》显然专长于那些“其实并没有真正发生过”的事情。但你可以回想一下我们自己的这些标准。结果是：马丁·莫尼斯 1，历史学家 0，我想是这样的。是的，这话说得没错。不过，汤姆，英国人这种主题……贯穿了整个葡萄牙的历史，不是吗？所以，我们是不是应该直接跳到 14 世纪？那是英国人重新出现在故事中的时期。你提到了爱德华三世和葡萄牙的斐迪南在 1372 年签署的条约。所以今年正是它的周年纪念日，对吧？哦，是的。是的。
I mean, the rest of history obviously specialises in things that didn't really happen. But you can think about those, our own standards. But Martin Moniz won. Historians, nil, I think. Yes, that's fair to say. But Tom, that sort of theme of the English, that sort of runs right through Portuguese history, doesn't it? So should we jump to the 14th century? It's when the English reappear in the story. You mentioned the treaty that Edward III and Ferdinand of
但其实在那之前的 1353 年，还有一个条约，那是一个商业条约。签署的主体不是国王对国王，而是商业港口对商业港口。那两个商业港口就是伦敦和波尔图。因此，伦敦和波尔图之间的这种贸易关系——日后将为波特酒（port wine）提供名称来源——是非常非常早的。所以我们向他们提供呢绒，而他们向我们提供葡萄酒、
Portugal signed in 1372. So this is the anniversary of it, isn't it? Oh, yes. Yeah. But there was actually one before that in 1353, and it was a commercial treaty, which was signed, not kind of king and king, but commercial port and commercial port. And the two commercial ports were London and a Porto. And so that trading relationship between London and a Porto, which in due course will give its name to port wine, is very, very early. So we're giving them cloth and they're giving us wine,
橄榄油、盐、软木，以及我们基本上无法自行获取的东西。而且我想，英格兰和葡萄牙也是天然的盟友。我的意思是，它们都是大西洋国家，面向海洋，同时它们也……它们都是边缘国家。是的，它们处在边缘，而且在它们中间隔着大国。对吧？所以——我不知道，比如莱昂王国或者法兰西王国，这大概是显而易见的例子吧。所以这种结盟在情理之中。这个同盟能够持续将近七个世纪之久，真是一件非凡的事情。这真的极其非凡，我认为这极大地反映了双方的光彩——对于葡萄牙人而言，是他们坚定不移地遵守诺言……当然，这在 1386 年的《温莎条约》中得到了进一步巩固。当时我们非常慷慨地送出了一位公主。
oil, olive oil, salt, cork, things that we can't get basically and i suppose it's also england and portugal are natural allies i mean they're both atlantic countries outward facing but they also and they're both peripheral yeah they're peripheral and they're sort of and there are big powers in between them yeah so i don't know the kingdom of leon or the kingdom of france it's the obvious one i suppose yeah so it sort of makes sense and it's an extraordinary thing that that that alliance has lasted basically the best part of seven centuries extraordinary and i think reflects tremendously well on both sides on the portuguese yeah you know our steadfast um keeping our word uh of course but it it's sealed, isn't it, by the Treaty of Windsor in 1386 when we very generously donate a princess.
那是冈特的约翰（John of Gaunt）的女儿，对吧？兰开斯特的菲利帕（Philippa of Lancaster）。是的，她是一位极其出色的女性。她曾师从伟大的诗人乔叟（Chaucer）、伟大的法国编年史家兼百年战争历史学家弗鲁萨尔（Froissart），以及——令人惊叹的是——约翰·威克里夫（John Wycliffe），汤姆，就是那个贝利奥（Balliol）的人！那个贝利奥的人，原型新教徒！所以，基本上……
So that's John of Gaunt's daughter, isn't it? Philippa of Lancaster. Yeah, who's a tremendously impressive woman. So she was taught by Chaucer, the great poet, by Froissart, the great French chronicler, historian of the Hundred Years' War, and by john whitcliffe amazingly a bailio man tom the bailio man the proto-protestant so um basically
她——我是说，她曾师从那个时代的顶尖知识分子。是的，顶尖的老师，顶尖的人物。但以新娘的标准来看，她年纪已经不小了，当时她 27 岁。据说当时很多葡萄牙人说：“这是个糟糕的举动，她年纪太大了，生不了孩子。”不过，你知道关于这场婚礼本身的细节吗？不知道，我很想听听，因为这场婚礼举行时，新郎——葡萄牙国王若昂一世（John I of Portugal）——并没有出席，因为他在葡萄牙，而菲利帕在英国。所以他们找了一个替身出席。然后据说当时葡萄牙有个习俗，当这种情况发生时，替身会假装陪新娘圆房。这可真是个令人震惊的场景。他们当时有那种……叫什么来着？亲密行为协调员吗？
she i mean you know she she was taught by the leading intellectual figures of the age yes top top teachers top people but she's quite old by bride standards so she's 27 and lots of portuguese people apparently at the time said this is a terrible move she's much too old to have children but you know do you know about the actual marriage i don't i'd like to hear about it because the marriage happened without the presence of um of the groom john john the first of portugal because he was in portugal and philippa was in england so they had a stand-in um And then apparently it was a Portuguese custom when this happened that the stand-in would pretend to bed her. So that's a striking scene. Did they have sort of, what are they called, intimacy coordinators?
是的，我不知道。我不知道当时是怎么运作的。但显然这是葡萄牙一个非常独特的习俗，我想这个习俗现在大概已经废止了吧。我正要问你，你在自己的婚礼上是不是也不得不雇一个替身呢？不过既然我听到了这个转折，我就不问了，因为这是一个非常具有自我 incriminating（自我指证）嫌疑的问题。好吧，我可不是葡萄牙人，所以我们可不会干那种事。不管怎样，菲利帕远嫁葡萄牙，嫁给了葡萄牙国王若昂（Jao，即约翰一世）。一切都取得了巨大的成功。
Yes, I don't know. I don't know how that operated. But apparently this was a very distinctive Portuguese custom that I imagine has since gone into abeyance. I was about to ask you if you had to employ a stand-in at your own wedding, but now that I've heard that twist, I won't ask you because it's a very incriminating question. Well, I'm not Portuguese, so that's not the kind of thing that we got up to. Anyway, so Philippa goes off to Portugal and she marries John, Jao, the first of Portugal. And it's all a tremendous success.
他当时已经有了一位非常美丽的情妇，而菲利帕长相相对普通。但最终，他却对她爱慕至极。她给他生了九个孩子，我想。他们被称为“显赫一代”（the illustrious generation）。我想，多米尼克，我们应该在这里休息一下。等我们回来后，我们应该解释一下他们是如何以及为什么被称为“显赫一代”的。嗯，因为其中一个孩子可以说是将要改变世界的人，对吧，汤姆？我的意思是，这不算太夸张吧？不，我认为这绝不过分。
He already has a mistress who's very beautiful and Philippa is rather plain. But he ends up absolutely adoring her. And she gives him nine children, I think. And they're known as the illustrious generation. And I think, Dominic, we should take a break here. And when we come back, we should explain how and why they are called the illustrious generation. Well, because one of those children is arguably going to change the world, isn't he, Tom? I mean, that's not too great an exaggeration. No, I think that's not too great an exaggeration.
中场休息后，一起来了解他是谁以及他做了什么。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。不过分。中场休息后，请访问 therestisentertainment.com 了解详情。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。在我们回到今天的节目之前，感谢我们的赞助商 Wine 52 提供我们在节目开始时谈到的那些美味的葡萄牙葡萄酒。多米尼克，我可以看到，在幕间休息时，你以最专业的风格开启了一瓶葡萄牙葡萄酒。其实我已经在喝第三瓶了，汤姆，在你说话的时候我喝了很多。好吧，是我眼花了吗？那瓶酒碰巧是 Quintas do Homem 酒庄的 Atua 吗？如果是的话，味道怎么样？太棒了。这酒……其实很讨人喜欢。它是一款白葡萄酒——好吧，我说是白葡萄酒，但其实是葡萄牙人所称的“绿酒”（vinho verde），这是一种……
After the break, find out who he was and what he did. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. exaggeration. After the break, find to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Before we get back to today's episode, thanks to our sponsors, Wine 52, for those lovely Portuguese wines we were talking about at the start of the show. Dominic, I can see that during the interval, in best best professional style you have cracked open a bottle of portuguese wine i'm on my third bottle actually tom i was drinking a lot while you were talking okay uh do my eyes deceive me or is that the atua by quintas do omem by any chance and if it is how is it beautiful it's so it's um it's lovely actually it's it's a white wine well it's i say white wine it's what the portuguese call a vinho verde which is um a kind of green wine and it's
由当地葡萄品种混合酿造的酒。所以这是一种非常具有海洋风味的酒。嗯，这很合适，对吧？对于葡萄牙来说。完全如此，恩里克斯航海家（Henry the Navigator）一定会喜欢的。所以它带有浓郁的甜瓜味、青柠味、青草味和柑橘味。非常清爽。你应该配着……我不知道，生蚝或者青口贝之类的海鲜一起喝。而且这绝对是一款高端产品，汤姆，我想这是葡萄牙最受欢迎的地区之一出品的。太棒了。好吧，其实我也刚打开了一瓶，我会在今天的节目结束时给你我的品鉴评价。为了听众着想，汤姆其实是直接对着酒瓶喝的，我绝对不建议这么做。我建议你还是先倒进杯子里。
made from a blend of uh local grape varieties so it's a sort of um it's very maritime wine well that's suitable isn't it for portugal exactly henry the navigator would love it um so it's very melony and limey and kind of grassy and citrusy. It's very light. You should have it with, I don't know, oysters or something or mussels. And it's definitely a sort of higher end offering, Tom, I would say from one of Portugal's best loved regions. Excellent. Well, I've actually just opened a bottle too, and I will give you my verdict on it at the end of today's episode. And just for listeners, Tom is actually drinking directly from the bottle, which I definitely don't recommend. I would pour it out first.
好了，如果你想领取你的那箱免费葡萄牙葡萄酒，你只需要访问 www.wine52.com/history。网址是 wine52.com/history，然后支付 8.95 英镑的邮费，就会有三瓶免费的葡萄酒送到你手上。好了，回到节目中。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，各位。汤姆，你在中场休息前，满怀激情地跟我们讲了兰开斯特的菲利帕的故事，你显然是她的超级粉丝。所以她远嫁葡萄牙——我想她大概是在 1387 年左右抵达的吧？当时我们已经与葡萄牙人签署了同盟条约，这在西班牙人看来显然是个大新闻。我们向他们出售鱼类和呢绒，而他们现在则向我们出售葡萄酒、软木、盐和……
Now, if you want to claim your free case of Portuguese wine, all you need to do is go to www.wine52.com slash history. That's wine52.com slash history and cover the postage costs of £8.95 and you will get three free bottles delivered to you. Right, back to the show. So welcome back to The Rest Is History, everybody. Tom, you were telling us before the break with great gusto about Philippa of Lancaster, who you're clearly a very big fan of. So she's gone off to Portugal. I think she arrives in what 1387 is it or something like that we have signed our alliance with the portuguese which is obviously spanish news for everybody we're selling them fish and cloth and they're now selling us wine and cork and salt and
油。你知道那些位于波尔图的英国仓库，它们就是今天你在杜罗河畔看到的那些著名波特酒酒庄的先驱。而且，正如你所说的那样，菲利帕获得了巨大的成功。她在 1415 年的夏天去世了，汤姆。据说在她临终弥留之际，有一阵风吹过房子。她问：“这是什么风？”有人回答：“陛下，这是北风，”或者类似的话。她接着说：“这对于我丈夫和儿子去非洲的航程来说，将是一场顺风。”随后她就去世了。然后她就去世了。那么，这到底是怎么回事呢？嗯，所以 1415 年在英格兰其实更因阿金库尔战役（Battle of Agincourt）而闻名，
oil you know these english warehouses in porto which are the sort of ancestors of the port wine great port wine houses that you see today on the banks of the Douro. And, well, Philippa is a tremendous success, as you were saying. She dies in the summer of 1415, Tom. And it is said that as she lies there dying, there's a wind that kind of blows through the house. And she says, what's the wind? And somebody says, it is the north wind,
菲利帕的侄子亨利五世（Henry V）正是在那里击败了法国人……她的儿子们都是典型的亨利五世式的人物。他们是伟大的勇士，同时又极其虔诚。他们将这两者融合在一起，形成了一种独特的信念感、目标感和侵略性——如果不用更委婉的词来形容的话。你会发现，其中有三个人格外引人注目。首先是杜阿尔特（Duarte，即爱德华），他后来成为了国王，是一位伟大的勇士；然后是佩德罗（Pedro，即彼得），他是一个见多识广、游历四方的人，足迹遍布各地；最后是恩里克（Enrique，即亨利），也就是在英语世界中被称为“航海家亨利”（Henry the Navigator）的人。这三个人都非常非常令人印象深刻。而菲利帕在临终前感受到的、吹拂着的这股风，正是将葡萄牙舰队从葡萄牙吹过海峡、驶向北非的顺风——具体目标是伟大的要塞休达（Ceuta）。
your majesty or whatever. And she says, that will be a great wind for my husband and son's voyage to Africa. And then she dies. And then she dies. So what's going on? Well, so 1415, of course, is better known in England for the Battle of Agincourt,
发音真标准，汤姆……谢谢。有些人现在可能知道休达，因为它基本上位于摩洛哥海岸上。但它实际上是西班牙的领土。它是一块飞地。这里曾是摩尔人极其坚固的据点之一，是北非海岸上伟大的贸易要塞之一。是的，所以休达和丹吉尔（Tangier）就是位于葡萄牙对岸北非海岸上的两座伟大要塞。在某种程度上，这也是葡萄牙登上世界舞台的序幕，不是吗？
where Philippa's nephew, Henryry v defeats the french um and her sons are very kind of henry v characters they are great warriors uh and they are terrifyingly devout and they kind of fuse it um into this kind of distinctive sense of conviction, purpose, and aggression, not to put too fine a word on it. And you get, I guess there are kind of three who stand out. So you have Duarte, Edward, who becomes the king, a great warrior. You have Pedro, Peter, who is a fabulously well-traveled man I mean he goes all over the place and then you have Enrique Henry who will come to be known in the English-speaking world as Henry the Navigator and but all three of them are very very impressive figures and this wind that Philippa as she lies
在这里，菲利帕的侄子亨利五世击败了法国人，她的儿子们非常具有亨利五世式角色的特点，他们是伟大的勇士，而且极其虔诚。他们将这种虔诚融合成了一种独特的信念感、目标感和侵略性，直白地说就是这样。你可以看到，我想有三个人非常突出。首先是杜阿尔特，也就是爱德华，他后来成了国王，是一位伟大的勇士；然后是佩德罗，也就是彼得，这是一个游历极其广泛的人，可以说是到处都去过；接着是恩里克，也就是亨利，在英语世界里他被称为“航海家亨利”。但这三个人都是非常非常了不起的人物，而这股菲利帕在临终时感受到的风
dying here is blowing is a wind that is blowing the portuguese fleet across the straits from portugal to to north africa and specifically to the great fort of ceuta beautiful pronunciation tom um thank you some people may know ceuta now because it's um basically on the moroccan coast but it's actually sp. It's an enclave. There was this sort of incredibly fortified sort of Moorish stronghold, one of the great kind of trading citadels of the North African coast. Yeah, so it's Souta and Tangier, the two great fortresses that are on the North African coast opposite Portugal. This is Portugal's sort of entrance onto the world stage in a way, isn't it?
正吹拂着葡萄牙舰队穿过海峡，从葡萄牙驶向北非，具体来说就是伟大的休达要塞。发音真标准，汤姆。谢谢你。有些人现在可能知道休达，因为它基本上位于摩洛哥海岸，但实际上它是西班牙的一个飞地。这是一个极其坚固的摩尔人据点，是北非海岸伟大的贸易堡垒之一。是的，所以休达和丹吉尔是北非海岸上与葡萄牙隔海相望的两大要塞。从某种意义上说，这也是葡萄牙登上世界舞台的入口，对吧？
Because up to this point, it's been one of multiple kind of small you know slightly sort of fly bit and iberian kingdom christian kingdoms it's still very poor it's basically they're all farmers and fishermen um there's only a million people and they go go across the sea. And they basically smash their way into the city. Yeah, they take them completely by surprise. I think they only lose eight men or something. It's a kind of storming victory. But then they capture it. And they realize that basically it's all been a waste of effort.
因为在此之前，葡萄牙只是众多小型、略带点微不足道的小伊比利亚基督教王国之一，它当时依然非常贫困，基本上全都是农民和渔民，嗯，人口只有一百万，而他们渡过了大海。然后他们基本上是强行闯入了这座城市。是的，他们打了个对手措手不及。我想他们好像只损失了八个人左右。这是一场堪称风暴般的胜利。但接着他们占领了那里。然后他们意识到，基本上这一切都是白费力气。
Because all the trade that was going to Tuta is now going to Tangier. And essentially, it's costing them an absolute fortune and they're making absolutely nothing from it. And then finally, the Portuguese do capture Tangier in 1471. So it's taken them a long time, but they do get both those great fortresses. And that's kind of a signal really that, as you say, Portugal has arrived as a kind of great great power so in due course um let's call him henry because we know him as henry the navigator in english so he's he's behaved very well in the in the capture he's won his spurs there so he's 21 he's 21 in 1415 yeah so wins his spurs great hero and in 1437 he tries to capture tang, and that goes disastrously wrong.
因为原本要运往休达的所有贸易现在都流向了丹吉尔。从本质上讲，这花费了他们巨额的财富，而他们却从中一无所获。直到最后，葡萄牙人在1471年终于占领了丹吉尔。所以他们花了很长时间，但他们确实拿下了这两座伟大的堡垒。这在某种程度上是一个信号，正如你所说，葡萄牙已经作为某种伟大强国登场了，所以在适当的时候，嗯，我们暂且叫他亨利吧，因为我们在英语里称他为航海家亨利，所以他在占领行动中表现得非常好，他在那里赢得了荣誉，所以他21岁，在1415年时他21岁，是的——所以赢得了荣誉，成为了伟大的英雄，而在1437年，他试图攻占丹吉尔，结果却惨败。
And he's defeated. He negotiates a safe passage for himself and his army back to Ceuta. And the moment he gets back to Ceuta, he reneges on the deal. So I'm afraid that that doesn't redound very well to him. That's kind of Germano Flemish behavior rather than, rather than English. So he's just to sort of paint a bit of a picture of him. He is.
而且他战败了。他为自己和军队争取到了安全返回休达的通道。而他一回到休达，就背叛了协议。所以我恐怕这并不能为他增添多少光彩。这更像是日耳曼-弗兰德斯的行为，而不是英国人的行为。所以他——这只是为了大致勾勒一下他的形象。他是。
I mean, you would love him, Tom. He is. Why? Because he thinks everything is very deeply Christian. Like you. Yeah.
我的意思是，你会喜欢他的，汤姆。他是。为什么？因为他认为一切都极其虔诚地关乎基督教。就像你一样。是的。
Yeah. But he likes, he likes ships. I'm less keen on ships. He, yeah, you're knocking on rope, I think, specifically. I'm not keen on rope.
是的。但他喜欢，他喜欢船只。我对船只没那么大兴趣。他，是的，你可能在敲打绳子，我觉得，具体来说。我对绳子不感兴趣。
That's your objection to the novels of Patrick O'Brien, who surely would admire Henry the Navigator. Anyway, he's very, very, he's a celibate. He never marries. He wears a hair shirt. You know, he's a very sort of strict. He's actually, you know your comparison with Henry V. Exactly.
这就是你对帕特里克·奥布莱恩小说的异议，他肯定会钦佩航海家亨利。无论如何，他非常非常，他是一个独身主义者。他从不结婚。他穿着苦修衣。你知道，他非常严格。实际上，你知道你拿他跟亨利五世作比较。没错。
It's that kind of militant asceticism yeah um makes him i think a very frightening figure so yes so so he's an he's militantly ascetic so he's he's a very austere figure tom but he's also visionary isn't he because when they talk suitor in 1415 i mean that's portugal has been on the periphery, and now they've sort of got a toehold in North Africa. And there's this sort of sense that beyond, there is all this stuff going on that they don't really know about. There are caravans crossing the Sahara, and there are spices, and there are ships coming from across the Islamic world. And there's this sort of, it's like they've got a glimpse into this vast trading network that they previously were slightly in the dark about. And there's, I don't know, cinnamon and cloves and all kinds of stuff that's very exciting for them. And I guess I would say Henry the Navigator's sort of his vision, he thinks that despite Portugal's poverty and its
正是那种强硬的苦修主义，嗯，这让我觉得他是一个非常可怕的人物，所以，是的，所以——所以他是个强硬的苦修主义者，所以他是一个非常严厉的人物，汤姆，但他也是个有远见的人，不是吗？因为当他们在1415年占领休达时，我的意思是，葡萄牙一直处于边缘地带，而现在他们在北非总算有了一个立足点。并且有一种感觉，那就是在更远的地方，正发生着各种他们并不真正了解的事情。有穿梭于撒哈拉沙漠的商队，有香料，还有来自整个伊斯兰世界的船只。有这样一种感觉，就好像他们窥见了那个庞大的贸易网络的一鳞半爪，而在此之前，他们对这个网络可以说是有些懵懂无知。而且有，我不知道，肉桂、丁香以及各种对他们来说极其兴奋的东西。我想我会说航海家亨利的这种愿景，他认为尽管葡萄牙很贫穷，且具有
peripheral nature, that they can get a piece of this. Yeah. Well, I think it's a blend, again, very Henry V of greed, a lust for wealth, for land, for all the good things that that brings, but also a kind of almost mystical sense of Christian militancy. Because Henry the Navigator is also very, very interested in destroying Islam. I mean, that's the scale on which he's thinking. He wants to destroy Islam and he wants to outflank the Muslim world. And he wants to discover this mysterious great Christian king who supposedly lurks beyond the limits of the world that the Portuguese know called Presto John, who is a kind of complete, it turns out to be a completely mythical figure,
边缘性，但他们可以从中分一杯羹。是的。嗯，我认为这再次融合了——非常像亨利五世——贪婪、对财富的渴望、对土地的渴望、对这一切美好事物所带来的一切的渴望，但同时也有一种几乎是神秘主义的基督教激进主义感。因为航海家亨利也非常非常热衷于消灭伊斯兰教。我的意思是，这就是他思考的格局。他想要消灭伊斯兰教，他想要迂回包抄穆斯林世界。他想要发现这个神秘的伟大基督教君王，据说他潜伏在葡萄牙人所知世界的边缘之外，名叫约翰长老，他是一个完全的——事实证明他是一个完全虚构的人物，
a kind of compound of all kinds of rumors that over the course of the Middle Ages have mixed together. And he never actually exists, but he serves the figure of Presto John, the idea that this great king exists tantalizingly just over the horizon, and that if only the Portuguese can establish contact with him, then they can forge an alliance and destroy Islam. I think that's also a kind, you know, as well as the kind of lust for spices and silks and jewels and so on. I think that that is also a key determinant. And in a way that it's hard to disentangle them, because they're kind of f let's sort of unpack some of this tom so first of all the the prester john stuff so this idea that there's basically this christian monarch out there in in africa somewhere or beyond
这是中世纪流传下来的各种谣言的结合体。他其实从来没有真正存在过，但他起到了约翰长老的作用——这种伟大的君王正若即若离地存在于地平线之上的想法，如果葡萄牙人能与他建立联系，他们就能结成同盟并消灭伊斯兰教。我认为这也是一种，你知道的，除了对香料、丝绸和珠宝等等的渴望之外。我认为这也是一个决定性因素。从某种程度上说，很难将它们剥离开来，因为它们是——让我们来剖析一下其中的一些内容，汤姆，首先是关于约翰长老的事情——也就是这种认为在非洲某个地方或伊斯兰世界之外
the the islamic world i mean there's sort of a grain of truth isn't that because there is a christian kingdom in ethiopia yeah they know that there are nestorian christians somewhere in asia yeah um so the sort of garbled rumors of this have reached the sort of western christendom and i suppose this fuses with your thing about anti-islam because of course the islamic world is on the march that constantinople is going to fall in 1453. The Turks are kind of carrying all before them in the Balkans and are expanding and expanding and going to reach their peak. I mean, they're not even going to reach their peak
基本上存在着这样一个基督教君主的想法，我的意思是，这其中其实包含着一丝真相，不是吗？因为埃塞俄比亚确实有一个基督教王国，是的，他们知道亚洲某处有聂斯托利派基督徒，是的，嗯，关于这一点的一些零碎谣言已经传到了西方基督教世界，我想这与你关于反伊斯兰教的观点融合在了一起，因为当然伊斯兰教世界正在进军，君士坦丁堡将在1453年陷落。土耳其人正在巴尔干半岛势如破竹，不断扩张，并且即将达到顶峰。我的意思是，他们甚至还没达到顶峰，
for another hundred years or so. So you can sort of see how there's this kind of, this ideological, this sort of almost apocalyptic sense. We absolutely have to launch a fight back. Yeah, well, I was just gonna say that the way that the kind of the militant Christianity and the greed fuse is the fact that obviously, the Muslim world controls the trade links to the East. So they control Egypt, they control the Red Sea, they control Mesopotamia and Iran so it's very very difficult for Europeans to get all these sources except through Muslim middlemen and so the dream of either destroying Islam or outflanking it
还要再过一百年左右。所以你可以看出这种意识形态上的、这种近乎末日般的意识形态感是如何产生的。我们绝对必须发起反击。是的，嗯，我正要说的是，激进的基督教和贪婪融合的方式在于，显然，穆斯林世界控制着通往东方的贸易路线。所以他们控制着埃及，他们控制着红海，他们控制着美索不达米亚和伊朗，因此欧洲人要想获得所有这些资源，除了通过穆斯林中间商之外，是非常非常困难的，所以无论是消灭伊斯兰教还是迂回包抄它的梦想——
yeah you could you could say well this is my Christian duty and it will enable me to get very rich you know that's everyone's a winner there yeah i mean i was just looking at what um i mean basically the pope gives them he gives him the navigator a kind of a remit and he says you can invade search out capture vanquish and subdue all saracens and pagans whatsoever and other enemies of christ and reduce their persons to perpetual slavery so from the sort of beginning there is a an enormously sort of aggressive side to this but it doesn't i guess you i mean if you're telling the story of the portuguese expansion it'd be wrong to i mean we will get into some some pretty gruesome scenes but there's also
是的，你可以说，嗯，这是我的基督教责任，它将使我变得非常富有，你知道，那是皆大欢喜的。嗯，我只是在看——我的意思是，基本上教皇赋予了他们——他赋予了航海家一项使命，他说你可以入侵、搜寻、俘虏、征服并制服所有的撒拉逊人、异教徒以及基督的其他敌人，并将他们沦为永久奴隶。所以从某种程度上说，一开始这就具有一种极其侵略性的侧面，但它并不——我想你可以——我的意思是，如果你在讲述葡萄牙扩张的故事，那将是错误的——我的意思是，我们会谈到一些相当血腥的场面，但其中也有
amazing technological innovation so henry basically has this place um some of you may be familiar with a beer called Sagres, and at Sagres, which is on the south of very southern sort of tip of Portugal, he gets all these cartographers and navigators and astronomers, Christians and Jews, and they're reading sort of Arab texts and sharing ideas. And they help to devise this new ship called a caravel. Are you familiar? Of course, you don't like ship design tom i know that it has flat bottom doesn't it it has it has a very shallow but i tend to actually understand ship design either i just repeat i'm just i'm just reading stuff that i've that i've repeated it's a flat bottom ship and it has crucially triangular sails. So, Dominic, explain to me why that matters.
惊人的技术创新。所以亨利基本上拥有这样一个地方——你们中的一些人可能熟悉一种叫萨格里什（Sagres）的啤酒，而在位于葡萄牙极南部岬角的萨格里什，他召集了所有这些制图师、航海家和天文学家，包括基督徒和犹太人，他们阅读阿拉伯文本并分享想法。他们帮助设计了一种叫做“卡拉维尔帆船”（caravel）的新型船只。你熟悉吗？当然，你不喜欢船舶设计，汤姆，我知道它有一个平底，对吧？它有一个非常浅的——不过我其实也不怎么懂船舶设计，我只是重复——我只是在阅读我复述过的内容。它是一艘平底船，最关键的是它拥有三角帆。所以，多米尼克，向我解释一下为什么这很重要。
Well, Tom, with a square sail, it's very hard. You can only effectively sail with a direct wind from a stern. Did you know that? Of course, everyone knows that. Okay, so you can only effectively sail with a direct wind from a stern. With a triangular sail, the world is your oyster. You can just crack on and... With your rates and your knots.
嗯，汤姆，对于方帆来说，这非常困难。你实际上只能借助顺风航行。你知道吗？当然，每个人都知道这一点。好吧，所以你只能借助顺风航行。有了三角帆，世界就在你的掌控之中了。你只需勇往直前……带着你的航速和节。
Yeah, absolutely. Now, this is absolutely first-class maritime technological analysis. So anyway, they've got these brilliant ships with these triangular sails called caravels. And actually, Portugal is well-placed, clearly sort of get out into the world and explore things. Could I just one thing on the ship, the Caravelle technology? Yeah, you want to hear more about the sails? No, I want to talk about the bottoms. So the reason why the flat bottom matters is because nobody in Portugal knows how far Africa stretches southwards, but they hope that perhaps there will be a river that leads from the west coast of Africa inland and will meet up with the Nile, thereby enabling ships basically to burst out into the Mediterranean or perhaps out into the Indian Ocean. And so this dream that there are rivers that will cut across
是的，绝对的。现在，这是绝对一流的海事技术分析。总之，他们拥有了这些带有三角帆的出色船只，叫做卡拉维尔帆船。事实上，葡萄牙处于有利地位，显然可以走到世界上去探索事物。我能就船只——卡拉维尔帆船技术说一点吗？是的，你想听更多关于帆的事情吗？不，我想谈谈船底。所以平底之所以重要，是因为葡萄牙没有人知道非洲向南延伸多远，但他们希望也许会有一条河流从非洲西海岸通往内陆，并与尼罗河交汇，从而使船只基本上能够冲入地中海，或者也许冲入印度洋。所以这种认为有河流可以横穿
the whole of Africa, that's something that Henry the Navigator is very, very into. And obviously, you need a very flat bottom ship to negotiate rivers. So that's my contribution. So Tom, you've been hiding this maritime technological light under a bushel. You know much more about ship design than you were letting on. Anyway, they will actually end up going up the Congo, going part of the way up the Congo. A fellow called Diego Cao, I think his name is. The Senegal, I think.
整个非洲的梦想，这是航海家亨利非常非常热衷的事情。显然，你需要一艘非常平底的船来在河流中航行。这就是我的贡献。所以汤姆，你一直在把这种航海技术的光芒藏在斗篷底下。你对船舶设计的了解远比你表现出来的要多。无论如何，他们最终会逆刚果河而上，沿着刚果河走了一段路。一个叫迭戈·康（Diego Cao）的人，我想他叫这个名字。塞内加尔河，我想。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, all kinds of rivers. All kinds of rivers. So some of them get washed up in Madeira. So they take Madeira in 1419. So that's out in the Atlantic. Then the Azores, they first colonized the Azores in 1539. And on Madeira, Dominic, don't they develop sugarcane?
对，没错。是的，各种各样的河流。各种各样的河流。所以其中一些船只被冲到了马德拉群岛。所以他们在1419年占领了马德拉。那是大西洋上的岛屿。然后是亚速尔群岛，他们在1539年首次殖民了亚速尔群岛。而在马德拉岛上，多米尼克，他们不是开发了甘蔗种植吗？
They do. So actually, you know the story that we tell in the West, or indeed in the world generally, about the conquest of the Americas, about globalization, about European expansion, which begins in 1492 with Columbus. That story is actually kind of wrong because Columbus had been selling himself around the Iberian courts to try and get sponsorship for his voyage for years before he ends up going in 1492. And one reason the Portuguese don't give him the contract
他们确实开发了。所以实际上，你知道我们在西方，或者确实在整个世界上讲述的关于美洲征服、关于全球化、关于欧洲扩张的故事——这个故事始于1492年的哥伦布。这个故事其实有点错误，因为哥伦布在1492年出发之前，多年来一直在伊比利亚各宫廷推销自己，试图为他的航行获得赞助。而葡萄牙人不给他合同的原因之一
is because they're well ahead of the game. They've already started doing it. So they've got Madeira and they've started... Henry the Navigator actually has the idea. He says, we could grow sugarcane here. Why don't we have kind of plantations? So you have the ancestor of what you're going to get in Brazil and elsewhere. They've got the Azores.
是因为他们遥遥领先。他们已经开始这样做了。所以他们拥有了马德拉，并且已经开始——航海家亨利其实有这样一个想法。他说，我们可以在这里种植甘蔗。为什么我们不建立某种种植园呢？所以你就有了你在巴西和其他地方将要看到的祖先。他们拥有了亚速尔群岛。
But as you said, I mean, most amazingly, at a time when England is, you know, Jack Cade's rebellion and the Wars of the Roses, the Portuguese are sailing down the coast of West Africa in these caravels. And they are charting all the capes. And as you said, they're sort of inching up the Senegal River. And they're grabbing islands also aren't they so they grab the cape verde islands they they grab sautome exactly and the first so 1444 i mean this is you talking about the dark side 1444 they raid an island called
但正如你所说，我的意思是，最了不起的是，在英国正经历杰克·凯德起义（Jack Cade's rebellion）和玫瑰战争的时期，葡萄牙人正驾驶着这些卡拉维尔帆船沿西非海岸南下。他们在绘制所有海岬的图表。正如你所说，他们正在塞内加尔河上一点一点地推进。而且他们还在夺取岛屿，不是吗？所以他们夺取了佛得角群岛，他们夺取了圣多美。完全正确，第一个——所以1444年，我的意思是，当你在谈论黑暗面时，1444年他们袭击了一个叫做
arguing island which is off the coast of mauritania and that's the first year that they basically take men african men women and children and they bring them back to sell them in the slave markets in lisbon and this is against the context i mean first of all there is slavery in portugal and what becomes spain in this period generally there are lots of slaves but obviously the mediterranean is a colossal slave trading marketplace. Lake, yeah. Yeah, it's a slave trading lake. So this is not, I mean, at the time, it doesn't seem like a huge deal, a new innovation. And they start doing it more and more.
阿尔金岛（Arguin island）的岛屿，该岛位于毛里塔尼亚海岸附近，那是他们基本上第一次抓捕非洲男人、女人和儿童，并将他们带回里斯本的奴隶市场出售。这是在这样的背景下发生的——首先，葡萄牙以及这一时期的西班牙本土普遍存在奴隶制，有大量的奴隶，但显然地中海是一个巨大的奴隶贸易市场。就像，是的。是的，它是一个奴隶贸易之湖。所以这并不是——我的意思是，在当时，这似乎并不是什么大不了的事情，也不是什么创新。他们开始越来越多地这样做。
So I think there are tens of thousands of Africans are brought back to Lisbon. Well, 20,000 apparently over the next 15 years. Yeah. And at the time, again, I mean, that sounds like an enormous number. But this is in a world in which tens of thousands of slaves are being shipped here, there, and everywhere all the time. So people don't actually remark on it at the time and say, gosh, this is a… It's still quite a novelty because apparently in the 1450s,
所以我想有成千上万的非洲人被带回了里斯本。嗯，据记载在接下来的15年里有两万人。是的。而在当时，再次强调，这听起来像是一个巨大的数字。但这发生在一个成千上万的奴隶一直被运往这里、那里和各地的世界里。所以人们在当时实际上并没有对此大加评论，并说，天哪，这简直是——这仍然是一个相当新鲜的事物，因为显然在1450年代，
the profit on a slave from Mauritania, so Morocco, it was estimated to be in at 700%. So that suggests that it's still quite, you know... I suppose the novelty of a black slave, I guess, in the slave markets of Lisbon. Yeah, I mean, this is a sort of chilling harbinger i suppose yes and of course and they're not only being brought back to the portuguese homeland they're also being taken to these infant plantations yeah that are being founded on in the in madeira and
来自毛里塔尼亚（即摩洛哥）的奴隶的利润据估计达到了700%。这表明它仍然相当……我想黑奴在里斯本奴隶市场上的新鲜感，我猜。是的，我的意思是，这是一种令人不寒而栗的预兆，我想是的，当然，他们不仅被带回葡萄牙本土，还被带到那些正在马德拉群岛和
the azores so yeah so that's absolutely the kind of the dark side of this dream of discovering the world that Henry is pushing. And I wonder, Dominic, should we leave it there with Portugal poised to go even further? Because I think it's clear by the time that Henry dies- Yeah, 1460 he dies that these rivers in that that they're finding on the west coast of africa are not actually going to lead to the uh to either to egypt or to the indian ocean and that therefore there is no choice if uh the portuguese are going to get to the indian ocean and the riches that lie beyond um they're going to have to go all the way down the coast of africa and bypass the continent and they don't even know if that's possible. And what happens is an incredible, I mean, such a colorful story, very blood-soaked, very dramatic. Just before we finish today's episode.
亚速尔群岛建立的初级种植园里。所以，是的，这绝对是亨利正在推动的探索世界梦想的黑暗面。我想知道，多米尼克，我们是否应该就此打住，此时葡萄牙正准备走得更远？因为我认为当亨利去世时——是的，他在1460年去世——很明显，他们在西非海岸发现的这些河流实际上并不会通往埃及或印度洋，因此，如果葡萄牙人要到达印度洋以及其后的财富，他们别无选择，只能一直沿非洲海岸南下，绕过这个大陆，而他们甚至不知道这是否可能。接下来发生的是一段令人难以置信的、我的意思是，如此丰富多彩的故事，充满血腥，非常戏剧化。在我们结束今天的节目之前。
Now, Tom, while I've been talking, I can't help but notice that you have been quaffing away at yet another Portuguese wine. And I think I'm right in saying that is the Cheiro Tinto from Lavradores de Vitória, isn't it? Trips off the tongue. What's the verdict? Is it good? Is it nice? Well, so it's red. I believe that the wine critics would describe it as vibrant and medium-bodied. And it is bursting with all the fruit flavors that one would associate with Portugal.
好了，汤姆，刚才我在说话时，我忍不住注意到你一直在畅饮另一款葡萄牙葡萄酒。我想我没说错吧，那是来自拉夫拉多雷斯·德·维托里亚（Lavradores de Vitoria）的谢罗红葡萄酒（Cheiro Tinto），对吧？名字真拗口。评价如何？它好喝吗？它不错吗？好吧，它是红酒。我相信酒评家会将其描述为充满活力且酒体中等。它散发着人们联想到葡萄牙的所有果香。
So ripe, dark plums, cherry aromas. So very fresh, very, dare I say, fruity on the palate. So, yeah, lovely. It's, I guess if I was to say it was silky as well. The kind of silks that Vasco da Gama would have brought back from India. So yeah, delicious and very Portuguese. Excellent. So listen, thank you so much.
所以成熟的黑李子、樱桃的芳香。非常清新，我敢说，口感上非常果香。所以，是的，很可爱。我想如果我说它也很丝滑的话。那种瓦斯科·达·伽马从印度带回来的丝绸。所以，是的，美味且非常葡萄牙。太好了。那么，听着，非常感谢。
Obrigado to Wine52 for sponsoring today's episode. Now remember that you too can join in Portuguese Wine Odyssey, or rather go on your own Portuguese Wine Odyssey if you go to www.wine52.com slash history, you will need to cover their postage costs of £8.95. But on the other hand, you will get three free bottles. You will get Glug magazine and you will get... Love Glug.
感谢Wine52赞助今天的节目。现在请记住，如果你访问 www.wine52.com/history，你也可以加入葡萄牙葡萄酒奇妙之旅，或者更确切地说是开启你自己的葡萄牙葡萄酒奇妙之旅，你需要支付8.95英镑的邮费。但另一方面，你将获得三瓶免费葡萄酒。你将获得《Glug》杂志，你将获得——我爱《Glug》。
You love Glug. And we love Glug magazine. It's actually one of my favourite magazines. You'll get Glug magazine and you will get, Tom, crucially, two tasty snacks delivered right to your door. And I think Dominic, you've already established you love a snack. Well, you love a wine. I love a snack. Everybody's happy. We all love Glug.
你爱《Glug》。我们也爱《Glug》杂志。这其实是我最喜欢的杂志之一。你会得到《Glug》杂志，而且你会得到，汤姆，至关重要的是，两份美味的小吃直接送到你的门前。我想多米尼克，你已经证明了你喜欢小吃。嗯，你喜欢酒。我喜欢小吃。大家都很高兴。我们都爱《Glug》。
Yeah. And we both love Glug. So listen, we will be back next time for part two of this epic history of Portugal series. And we will see you then. Goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
是的。我们俩都爱《Glug》。所以，听着，我们下次会回来继续收听葡萄牙史诗般历史系列的第二部分。我们到时见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要收听独家节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票的权利，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。